will there be paranormal investigators
or maybe some unbounded Urban chaos or
will it stay completely true to the
spirit of the games here's everything
you need to know before you watch the
Five Nights at Freddy's movie Five
Nights at Freddy's is a popular horror
video game franchise originally created
by Indie developer Scott cofin the first
edition was released in 2014 and its
massive success led to multiple sequels
spin-offs and fan mods there's also been
a series of books that expands on the
franchise's Deep lore and after over a
decade stuck in development Hell
blumhouse Productions will be releasing
a big budget feature film adaptation of
FNAF in October
2023 the initial release was a
firstperson point-and-click horror game
in which players take on the role of a
security guard stuck in the rundown
Chuck-E-Cheese inspired Freddy Fazbear's
Pizza during the first few nights the
player is given instructions by an
unnamed predecessor who recounts the
dangers of the gig the creepy killer
animatronics that stock the restaurant
at night the player's only course of
action is to close the doors when
they're near but they can't keep the
door shut indefinitely because otherwise
they lose power and become defenseless
the sequels expand on this simple
premise with different time periods
hidden mini gamess and a Shakespearean
familial drama that drives the whole
plot at this point five nights at
Freddy's might be one of the most
recognizable horror franchises in the
world most of its success can be
attributed to the killer designs of the
game's animatronic antagonists but Scott
cen's greatest Triumph probably would
have never happened without his biggest
failure as it turns out those
frightening designs can be traced back
to a very different Rather cutesy game
that free-to-play mobile game designed
by CN was called chipper and Sons Lumber
Co it was meant to be fun and
kid-friendly but the character designs
ended up being a little too scary when
they were supposed to be endearing
beforehand CN had been making wholesome
Christian games but the reception to
chipper and Son's Lumber Co seemed to be
what convinced him to Pivot to horror
Five Nights at Freddy's was a hit pretty
much right out the gate when the first
game was released back in 2014 plus its
lack of Gore and campy comedic touches
allowed it to be safe enough for younger
audiences so Hollywood naturally saw
dollar signs flashing and attempts to
make a film adaptation began in Earnest
back in 2015 just a year after the first
game's release Gil Kennan who helmed the
2015 Poltergeist remake was the first
director attached with Seth Graham Smith
listed as a producer eventually though
they both left the project due to
constant delays on Scott coffin's part
then blumhouse Productions bought the
rights to the game and hired Chris
Columbus to write and direct as he was
apparently a big fan of the game however
he too eventually left the project after
many rewrites and doovers of the film's
script finally Emma Tommy landed the
director gig off the strength of her
feature debut 2018s the wind a film
adaptation of Five Nights at Freddy's
will likely live or die by the quality
of its monstrous animatronics they must
stay true to the spirit of the games
while also being believable as cute and
cuddly mascots and most important they
must be legitimately scary that's no
easy task luckily the famous Jim Henson
Creature Shop will be responsible for
creating Freddy Fazbear and his friends
in the movie The Jim Hensen company
should need no introduction as they're
the Geniuses behind such classic media
properties as the Muppets Sesame Street
Labyrinth and the '90s Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles so kudos to Blum House for
not going the CGI route and hopefully
the rest of the film will be just as
good as the character
designs
despite its humble beginnings the Five
Nights at Freddy series actually
features a surprisingly epic and dense
Lord that spans many decades for
instance there's ample evidence that the
first game is set in the mid90s this
includes the date on a check of Friday
November 12th that narrows it down to
1993 as that was the only time that that
day month and date all coincided during
the game's timeline and the minimum wage
on the check of $4 per hour fits that
era as well this could potentially
indicate that the film will be a period
piece Five Nights at Freddy's 2 is
explicitly set in 1987 in the first
teaser for the film there's a screaming
security guard who's presumably FNAF 2
protagonist Jeremy Fitzgerald this
potentially depicts the infamous Bite of
87 that's constantly mentioned
throughout the series both trailers
feature Matthew Lillard as Steve Raglin
a character who many fans are theorizing
may be the series antagonist William
Afton and aton's postmodem form
springtrap if this is true we could see
Afton as a human in the Flash backs and
springtrap throughout the rest of the
film this would also mean that the film
is merging game continuity since
springtrap doesn't become a true
antagonist until the third game in the
first five nights at Freddy's game the
security guard that the player controls
is named Mike Schmidt who will be played
in the film by Josh Hutcherson at the
end of the first game it's mentioned
that Schmidt was fired for messing with
the killer animatronics and that's
supposedly the last we ever hear of him
however there's a popular fan theory
that posits that Mike Schmidt and
Michael Aton are actually the the same
person in the games Michael Aton is the
son of deranged antagonist William Aton
AKA springtrap and the protagonist of
Five Nights at Freddy's sister location
in which he makes his first official
appearance the evidence for this Theory
mostly stems from ancillary material for
instance the activity book survival log
book which is made to look like an
instruction manual for Freddy Fazbear
pizza security guards is said to have
been owned by Mike with no last name
provided in the games only Mike Schmidt
is known to work at the restaurant but
the survival log book also mentions
events from the sister location game
that only Michael Aton would know about
it seems possible that the movie will
confirm or debunk this Theory hi this is
Mike death and tragedy befalling
innocent children is a common plot point
in many popular horror franchises and
Five Nights at Freddy's certainly
carries on that tradition one such
juvenile victim that gets particular
attention in FNAF has been dubbed the
crying child he's the main character
that you can troll in Five Nights at
Freddy's four as his backstory is
revealed through a series of mini gamess
according to lore the crying child was
bullied by his older brother at Freddy
Fazbear's pizza and he was then bitten
by an erratic Fazbear animatronic before
dying in a since deleted Instagram post
the actor playing young Mike in the
movie Wyatt Parker wrote nice to see my
little brother again over a picture of
himself with fellow actor Lucas Grant
many fans have theorized that the crying
child is Michael aton's little brother
and if Michael Schmidt and Michael Aton
are indeed the same person
that means that Mike accidentally
killing his brother could also be the
tragic event that's the source of his
guilt like a lot of horror game
franchises the various Five Nights at
Freddy sequels usually follow different
protagonists in each subsequent entry so
after Mike Schmidt in the original game
there's the ill-fated security guard
Jeremy Fitzgerald in Five Nights at
Freddy's 2 and then the crying child in
Five Nights at Freddy's 4 in 2019 Five
Nights at Freddy's help wanted was
released and it was eventually revealed
that the game's protagonist was the
female security guard Vanessa she then
becomes the antagonist in 2021s Five
Nights at Freddy's security breach
having been corrupted by yet another
incarnation of the evil William Aton
it's rumored that the police officer
character of Vanessa in the movie is the
same Vanessa from the games if that's
true it remains to be seen if the movie
Vanessa will share the same fate as her
video game counterpart or if the
filmmakers will do something different
with her since she's already changed
from a security guard to a police
officer the police search Freddy's top
to bottom
it's no secret that there have been a
lot of terrible video game adaptations
over the decades from the liveaction
version of Super Mario Brothers to
whatever the heck House of the Dead was
supposed to be video game movies have
often been rightly maligned on Plenty of
occasions a few years ago Scott coffin
spoke candidly on Reddit about the
lengthy production process and constant
delays plaguing the highly anticipated
Five Nights at Freddy's movie adaptation
he also revealed the various script
ideas that were pitched and then later
rejected before landing on the final
version that was used as the basis for
the 2023 movie CN dubbed the first
script that was written without his
involvement the F script whose synopsis
was a group of teenage troublemakers
break into Freddy's chaos ensues
according to CN there was no mention of
any main characters from the games and
it was too generic of a premise for a
FNAF movie it would have been yet
another adaptation of a video game to
add protagonists that weren't present in
the original ultimately cofin passed on
that version Five Nights at Freddy's has
proven popular enough to inspire lines
of toys clothes and even a long-running
book series one of those books is the
Silver Eyes which was co-written by
Scott
coffin however despite that creative
input from The Game's Creator the Silver
Eyes doesn't follow the exact continuity
of the games it tells the story of the
character Charlotte who returns to her
hometown years after a deadly tragedy
involving Freddy fazbears she meets up
with her old friends and they decide to
visit Freddy Fazbear's pizza then in
classic Horror Story fashion they're
chased and almost killed K by the
possessed animatronics the silver eyes
may just be an ancillary tie-in book but
it was ultimately chosen by coffin as
the spine of the eventual film
adaptation that's probably because it
already had characters with emotional
arcs clear motivations and enough
dialogue to turn into a script it might
seem like it would have been an easier
translation to the big screen especially
considering the fact that the games have
mostly silent protagonists however as
this was coffin's first attempt at
screenwriting the various early drafts
weren't very good even by his own
admission
paranormal TV shows like Ghost Hunters
and Ghost Adventures were a dime a dozen
in the mid 2000s thanks to their low
production costs and easy to produce
spectacle and apparently there were
plans to take the Five Nights at
Freddy's movie in this direction as
Scott cofin revealed on Reddit the story
was about a group of amateur ghost
trackers sneaking into an abandoned
Freddy's who's in here with us what the
heck was that like the first attempt at
adapting FNAF into a film the ghost
tracker version of the story focused on
original characters instead of people
from the games it does at least sound
like there was some sort of internal
logic to this version but It ultimately
strayed too far from The Game's lore and
CN agreed as he wrote on Reddit although
a very common sense setup for this sort
of movie the problem again arose about
how to give these characters a
connection to Freddy's itself what ended
up happening was too much of the story
went to their own backstories and their
own hardships and it took the spotlight
away from the story of Freddy's there
was yet another script treatment that
was pitched for the movie before Scott
CN became officially involved
he described it on Reddit simply as the
plushies Take Manhattan screenplay not
much is known about this version beyond
the fact that cin wasn't exactly happy
with it apparently the problem was the
very premise itself and the verdict was
that it was quote burned with fire if we
had to speculate this would have been
the sort of movie in which monsters
Rampage through a city thus it probably
wouldn't have the same claustrophobic
feel as the games which is a huge part
of their appeal large walking
animatronics could potentially be scary
in any situation to be sure but in an
urban setting it's theoretically much
easier to run away and escape from the
lumbering robots on the other hand being
trapped in a rundown Pizzeria makes
Escape much more difficult also this
type of narrative is a different type of
horror than FNAF is known for after all
Freddy Fazbear and his friends are
mostly creepy rather than outright
violent monsters who go out of their way
to kill people left and right all things
considered the death count in fap is
relatively low in fact in most canonical
endings the protagonists are usually
fired rather than killed
ultimately a script for the FNAF movie
was finalized and here's what we know
about the plot a down on his luck
regular guy named Mike is searching for
a job he ends up finding a seemingly
easy one night security at defunct pizza
party joined Freddy Fazbear's Pizza he's
hired by a man named Steve Raglin who
tells Mike that even though the
restaurant has been closed for a while
the owner isn't quite ready to let go of
it all you have to
do just keep your eyes on the monitor
Mike is late on his rent so he ignores
the job JS warning signs and heads out
for his first shift he takes along his
kid Sister Abby and we know right away
from how cute she is and how much her
big brother loves her that she will soon
be in life-threatening danger that
danger arrives in the form of Freddy
Fazbear's star attractions they're a
band of broken down animal animatronics
who once sing happy songs but now
they're instead motivated by a taste for
the blood of children if Mike can't
figure out how to stop them he might not
survive his Five Nights at Freddy's and
neither will Abby Scott cin has long
been vocal about ensuring that the movie
will be something that the Five Nights
at Freddy's fan base will want to see
but who exactly is that fan base the
FNAF games have a DieHard online
following that mostly consists of men in
their 20s and 30s but anyone who's
walked through any establishment that
sells books has surely seen the withered
faces of the Fazbear animatronics
staring up from the kid section plus the
movie has a killer cast with an indie
horror director at the helm so it might
just manage to appeal to viewers old
young and new why do I always get the
weirdos
there's a campy heartfelt energy on
display in the Five Nights at Freddy's
trailers as well as no shortage of jump
scares it looks like a delightful mix of
the horror comedy of the child's play
series as well as the spooky lore of a
Nightmare on Elm Street there's also
plenty of winking at the camera as well
as hints of an Earnest Redemption quest
Five Nights at Freddy's could also
attract the family-friendly horror
audience of something like stranger
things or conversely its attempts to
appeal to a larger group of horror fans
beyond the gaming fan base could lead to
unmitigated disaster our prediction and
hope is that it will land somewhere near
Megan on the scary versus silly scale in
October 2022 it was announced that
director Emma Tommy would take the Helm
of the Five Nights at Freddy's movie and
this is far from her first horror Rodeo
she initially made a name for herself by
co-directing 2014's Fair chase a
documentary about extreme Runners she
followed up with her feature directing
debut the 2018 horror Western the wind
and directed The thrilling Fiction
podcast the Left Right game which
starred Tessa Thompson Jason Blum for
one has also been very complimentary of
Tommy's cinematic skills as he declared
to The Hollywood Reporter in 2022 with
Emma Tommy at the helm we're committed
to making Scott's vision of the movie
come to life rest assured it will be and
is worth the wait in addition to
directing Five Nights at Freddy's Tommy
also co-wrote the script along with
Scott coffen and fellow Indie filmmaker
Seth
CAC the Five Nights at Freddy's movie
has already lived and died many times on
its path to the screen almost a will
have passed since its initial
announcement in 2015 and the actual
release in
2023 the film has changed creative hands
multiple times throughout that process
one of the directors who almost ended up
getting the gig was Chris Columbus but
he didn't stick around that loss might
seem a little surprising as the Director
behind home alone in the first two Harry
Potter movies would seemingly have been
a good fit for a PG-13 animatronic
scarefest it was back in 2018 the
deadline reported that Columbus had
signed on to write and direct the FNAF
movie but but then in 2021 producer
Jason Blum confirmed to collider that
Columbus had left the
project Columbus hasn't said anything
publicly about what went down though
Blum did tell collider I don't have the
right to do anything Scott doesn't like
basically Scott has kind of like the
equivalent of Final Cut and it's taken
longer than I hoped to get the right
story as detailed by Scott cn's
extensive list of gripes on Reddit in
2020 there have been plenty of scripts
that he wasn't happy with over the
course of production ultimately he did
like one script enough to co-write it
himself that would of course be the one
for the Five Nights at Freddy's movie
that's actually being released in
October 2023 so while Chris Columbus is
no longer working on the FNAF lick
there's no need to fret about the status
of his career looking ahead he's one of
The Producers on Robert Edgar's upcoming
Nos veratu and he's also reportedly
written a script for Gremlins 3 the Five
Nights at Freddy's movie trailer
features Matthew Lillard chewing the
scenery as sniveling career counselor
Steve Raglin Steve may also be the not
so secret serial killer William Affton
and he seemingly knows the Sinister
truth behind the demise of Freddy
fazbears it's obvious even from the
preview that Lillard is making a real
meal out of this role this is a fine
casting Choice as Lillard is no stranger
to dangerous characters his most iconic
horror performance is surely Stu mocker
in the original scream and then he
showed up in 2001's 13 Ghosts a remake
of the 1960 horror film of the same name
he can also hold it down in a cartoony
franchise as evidence by his work as
Shaggy in the Scooby-Doo movies so
clearly he's more than ready to spend
every night that he needs to be able to
survive Freddy's with that in mind
Lillard casually dropped that he signed
a three picture deal for Five Nights at
Freddy's during a January 2023
appearance on the podcast weekly MTG
time will tell if this ends up being
just as legendary as some of his earlier
roles but our hopes are certainly High
these days you got to have a sequel Five
Nights at Freddy's won't be the first
time that Josh Hutson is playing someone
who works long hours somewhere sketchy
from 2017 to 2020 he played the main
character of Josh on the Hulu comedy
series future man Josh is a janitor who
beats an unbeatable video game and is
then joined by The Game's characters in
a quest to truly change the future
hutchon is also of course well known for
his time as Peta malar in The Hunger
Games franchise Hutcherson's capacity
for conveying heartache comedy and
duplicity makes his casting as Mike
Schmid and FNAF particularly exciting
even in the trailers it's clear that
he'll make viewers feel sympathetic to
his flight
Hutcherson is also quite capable of
playing to villainous and surprising
strengths like when he's Charming the
blue hair off of Stanley tui's Caesar
flickerman in The Hunger Games or when
he's making Katniss everine question
whether his love for her is real or all
just a show for his own Survival he's
sure to bring similar nail-biting acting
abilities to Five Nights at
Freddy's the Five Nights at Freddy's
movie also Stars Elizabeth L as Vanessa
the seemingly sympathetic cop who
introduces herself to Mike Schmidt on
one rainy night she of course spills the
tea about the killer animatronics in
their spine tingling backstory viewers
May recognize L from her roles as Anna
on Once Upon a Time and as Mac in the
20122 movie mac and Rita she also played
gwi ofir Beck the first object of Joe's
Obsession on the Thriller series you
this might be a cynical take but we're
not exactly inclined to blindly trust
the one person in town who seems to know
everything about the ghost children
operating the animatronics from Beyond
their graves even newcomers to Five
Nights at Freddy's might smell a rat
with all of Vanessa's seemingly helpful
hints so is she Mike's Friend or Foe
regardless of what we know from the
games the movie could go potentially in
any diabolical Direction so we'll just
have to wait and see a big part of the
success of Five Nights at Freddy's can
be attributed to the spirited
playthrough videos posted by The Gaming
Community on YouTube and twitch so it
only makes sense then that the FNAF
movie looked to this very Community for
some stunt casting YouTube Stars 8bit
Ryan baz dco Fusion Z gamer and Cory
Kenshin pop up in the movies trailer and
there might be even more in the whole
thing
if you're a YouTuber yourself these
handles may very well have you amped out
of your mind but if on the other hand
these names mean nothing to you worry
not you can be excited instead about
Matthew Lillard's presence and explain
who he is to the nearest youngster how
do you do fellow kids in 2021 Scott cin
stepped away from the Five Nights at
Freddy's gaming franchise this was
seemingly due to controversy surrounding
the public disclosure of his campaign
donations to Republican politicians
including Donald Trump and Senator Mitch
McConnell this members of the lgbtqia
community and CN responded to the
controversy by saying on Reddit I'd like
to think that the last 7 years would
have given me the benefit of the doubt
in regards to how I try to treat people
but there I was trending on Twitter for
being a homophobe if I get canceled then
I get cancelled if people think I'm
doing more harm than good now then maybe
it's better that I get canceled and
retire but cin hasn't retired completely
as he released a new game in 2021 and he
co-wrote the FNAF movie Five Nights at
Freddy's is inspired by the look and
feel of a true life Terror Charles
entertainment cheese AKA chuckecheese
that place of business is ostensibly
where a kid can be a kid but it's also
where kids can be scared of the giant
creatures singing at them while they eat
pizza and cake and play some ski ball
the family entertainment center
delighted and haunted countless children
celebrating their birthdays in the 7s '
80s and '90s it still exists today but
in a much more stripped down version
unlike Freddy fazbears Chuck-E-Cheese
never experienced any killer bite of 80
three scenario even if the fan base has
tried to link some truly tragic events
that happened at chuck-e-cheese's into
the lore of FNAF in real life Chuck E
cheese did start phasing out its own
animatronic band in 2017 just 2 years
after the FNAF movie was first announced
even if that decision wasn't officially
related to Freddy's the timing is still
spooky enough to make you think twice
about ever stepping into a
Chuck-E-Cheese ever
again